the coronavirus pandemic is
raging again in europe and new rules are
going into place to slow it down
that's led to violent protests in places
like italy
europe now reports nearly half of the
world's new coveted cases
1.3 million just last week
an all-time high seth doan is in rome
seth how's that country responding to
that
well anthony there are new rules and
regulations for a while now we've had to
wear these masks both outside
and inside now the newest restrictions
include
a curfew that all restaurants have to
close after 6 p.m
and gyms and pools are also closed there
have been some protests scattered
protests around the country
and in some cases various extremist
groups have hijacked those protests
sparking violence
overnight police in riot gear fired tear
gas
to push back protesters that had set
fires in the northern cities of turin
and milan
while most protests against the
government restrictions curfew
enclosures have been peaceful
italy's national police tell cbs news
these scenes are the result
of instigators from far right far left
and organized crime groups
who've infiltrated and carried out
violence
across europe coronavirus cases are
spiking
this chart shows the surges since
september look at germany
spain the united kingdom and france
which now has the fifth
highest number of cases globally spain
the first european country to have more
than one million confirmed cases
declared a second state of emergency
governments in the world health
organization are urging everyone take
personal responsibility and limit
contact
we can avoid national lockdowns we can
avoid
massive restrictive movements if
everyone plays their part
those pleas to lessen community spread
are also coming from europe's hospitals
in belgium doctors in one city have been
asked to keep working
even if they have coronavirus but
overall death rates are down and those
admitted to critical care
are more likely to survive we feel
we can offer every patient the best
possible opportunity to get through it
based on some much firmer science that
we can draw on
now the prognosis for businesses is
less encouraging september was the first
month for us
that we started to go in the right way
so
now we have to stop again
you can see that the square behind me
here many of the streets are relatively
empty far fewer people
than there normally would be for the
most part italians are
quietly cooperating with these
restrictions and gail i would say there
is really more
fear here than anger fear of returning
to where we were
at the pandemics peak back in the spring
yeah
thank you seth stone i think that's what
we all feel is fear
but did he say that doctors even if they
have it or are you told they've got to
go back to work
in one in one place i don't understand
that at all but it is i mean i think
you understand why some people are upset
it's very disheartening people
in europe as well as here people have
worked so hard to try to get through
this and to have to go backwards
uh it's you know it's a long fight but
this tells you this virus is
is is stubborn and thriving yep
and will surge back if you if you let
down your guard 6 pm dinner curfew is
pretty early in a country where they
don't even eat till seven or later
yeah and it's going to take a collective
sacrifice we keep saying that
i know he's got to wear your mouth it's
so hard for these businesses nobody
likes wearing a mask i get that